Virginia Woolf and poetry Norma's seen
and noticed me being young was getting
so old
cheap beer cigarettes life was like a
movie said nothing nothing ever knew but
in times of trouble I turn to my mother
and I know that she go understand so at
age 18 I cried mother is she - there are
moments when your for truth but you're
sure you don't know these other speak so
loud just like this not oh god
everybody's got slaw and everybody plays
they pay me on the radio everything was
changing so I thought I was all the way
wrong but I can still remember that cold
November when I realized the mall but in
times of trouble I can turn to my mother
and I know that she go understand so at
age 22 I cried to my mother and she told
me there are moments when your phone to
down but you owe me
you always have to speak so loud no just
some start life is better in you you
don't always have the axial No
that's right
you know if I'm speaking truthfully I'm
not who I used to be and I know some
people might lie cuz my music doesn't
sound the same now I got my head shaved
I'm worried if I'm on the right path but
in times of trouble I can turn to my
mother and I know that she go understand
so at age 27 I speak with my mother and
she tells me there are moments when you
fall to the ground but you are stronger
than you feel you are now home or you
don't always have to speak solo just be
as you are
and life is not always a comfortable
ride everybody's got scars that they
have and everybody plays a fool sometime
so just be as you are